bon courage tenez
non je vais pas parler en anglais mais
avec ces simples mots vous vous avez
déjà formé un préjugé sur moi
conditionnait par vos réflexes sicot
logique quand on s'appelle des biais
aussi naturel que les réflexes
physiologique
notez bien aussi que j'ai un accent mon
accent est conditionné par mes origines
britanniques alors ça peut vous crispé
un peu mais mettez-vous dans mes
chaussures utilisées
cette crispation pour aiguiser votre
écoute et de mieux comprendre
je vais parler de ces pièges
psychologique et à la fin j'espère de
vous proposer un outil pratique à les
neutraliser
alors tout commence quand j'ai ouvert
mes rideaux
quand je suis arrivé à clermont ferrand
et j'ai vous cette magnifique panorama
de la chaîne depuis j'ai vu cette
silhouette
il m'a embêté il y avait quelque chose
qui clochait
cette école que j'étais en face de
quelqu'un qui avait un gros bouton sous
le nez à côté du puy de dôme le point
culminant
il a un espèce de bosses le petit puy de
dôme alors pour moi comme un
volcanologue
c'est pas comme une conne d'éruptions
qui jette des bornes c'est ni dôme de
lave qui s'accumulent lentement c'était
quelque chose d'autre j'ai pas compris
donc comme scientifique quand je
comprend pas quelque chose je pars sur
un voyage de découverte sur le petit puy
de dôme
j'ai marché là dessus j'ai volé en petit
avion en ulm
j'ai utilisé tous mes pouvoirs de
géologues pour le comprendre et ça
m'avait pris quelques années mais à la
fin j'avais découvert un type de volcans
rarissime qui s'appelle un cratère de
soulèvement qu'est-ce qui se passe la
lave arrive en dessous de la terre ils
arrivent ils s'accumulent et le surface
bon ben ça gonfle ça soulève ça soulève
pour créer une arche et le toit de
l'arche tombe pour créer cette cratère
de soulèvement j'étais très fier de moi
d'avoir trouvé ce nouveau type de
volcans j'ai pensé par exemple d'une
prix nobel sauf n'y en a pas pour les
géologues
on n'est pas appréciée comme
scientifique
quelque chose m'interroger parce que
j'ai trouvé que quelqu'un d'autre à ma
déception a déjà décrit ce volcan il ya
plus de 200 ans
leopold von bourg est arrivé à clermont
ferrand où fin du xviiie siècle
il a vu le petit puy de dôme il a
compris qu est-ce que c'était beaucoup
plus vite que moi et il a créé intérêt
théorique qui s'appelle des créateurs de
soulèvement à cette époque là la
géologie venait de naître conscience en
même temps un britannique
le jane l'eau est arrivée avait souvent
il a vu le suivent en éruption
donc il ya une théorie des cratères
d'éruption entre les deux une vraie
guerre déclenchée
c'était dur les deux parties sont pris
des positions et le combat est arrivé à
son apogée sur l'etna
là les supporteurs des cratères de
soulèvement une autre théorie que les
lave et on lit qu'yves pourrait se figer
que sur le plat c'est évident on sait
comme de l'eau donc par inférence toutes
les volcans qu'ils ont des pentes sont
que des cratères de soulèvement
si vous allez sur le volcan etna vous
allez voir que les lave qui sont et
route et se fige parfaitement sur les
pentes très incliné c'est évident james
là elle a pu détruire la théorie des
cratères de soulèvement l'idée était
ridiculisé et complètement perdus
oubliés
si on revient oublier cycle logique on
peut voir l'action de ses billets dans
cette
combattre cette guerre entre ces
scientifiques il ya quatre billets qui
sont importants ici le premier c'est le
biais de langage
le premier élément vue c'est le plus
fortement retenue donc vent debout
il arrive à clermont ferrand il voit le
petit puy de dôme il voit tout de suite
qu'est ce que c'est mais après il est
conditionné par sa james là elle arrive
dans la baie de naples
il voit un joli éruption du vésuve ces
idées sont bétonnées dans cette
direction le deuxième bien s'habiller de
confirmation le confirmation c'est ont
choisi où on accepte que l'information
qui va dans le sens de notre idée de
départ
on voit ça dans les choix des cas dans
cette histoire le troisième c'est le
cadrage ou le biais culturel ongrais
narratif autour de notre idée en
utilisant et en gonflant les
informations que nous avons choisie pour
arriver un but le 4e le biais de
l'intéressé le biais de l'intéressé sait
où en est on attribue à nous tous les
bons sentiments
tous les bons éléments tous les bons
action et on réinjecte sur les autres
tous les fautes tous les éléments
mauvais c'est ça qui a créé la guerre
entre les deux positions
c'est peut-être une histoire des
scientifiques j'ai le même type de
cerveau ça fonctionne de la même façon
on peut regarder un exemple beaucoup
plus quotidienne
je suis un coordinateur à l'université
de master international la langue de
communication dans les sciences
c'est l'anglais
donc c'était évident pour moi à utiliser
on prédominance l'anglais pour
l'enseignement dans ces masters
j'étais bouleversé très supris pouvoir
la résistance de mes collègues à cette
idée une vraie guerre
en effet déclenchée entre nous on a pris
des positions très différents j'ai vous
l'aidiez en train de marcher je ne
savais pas quoi faire
et un jour je suis allé à mon cours de
français et mon super prof fabienne
m'avait donné un jeu de rôle de prendre
la partie de membres de l'académie
française qui proposait que le français
devrait être le seul langue utilisée
dans l'enseignement supérieur
je connaissais tout les arguments
utilisés par mes collègues
donc j'ai commencé de jouer le rôle à
fond et après certains moments j'ai
trouvé que j'ai commencé à croire ce que
j'ai dit c'est comme en effet que j'ai
développé deux têtes
je suis devenu un monstre mais c'est pas
de tête mais dont le même cerveau
j'avais deux idées opposées en même
temps ça ne troublait dans la langue
sicot logique
ça s'appelle la dissonance cognitive
après cette séance mais de tête ont
convergé
est ce que j'ai trouvé c'est que j'avais
développé un empathie pour mes opposants
je les comprenais mieux le point de
départ je pourrai mieux discuter avec
eux parce que je connais c'est mieux
ce qui voulait dire ce que j'avais fait
je vais me mit dans les chaussures de
mes adversaires ou mieux en effet
j'avais pris une chaussure de mes
adversaires mais je vais garder ma
chaussure aussi j'ai porté les deux
chaussures ce que je vous propose
faire un exercice chaque jour peut-être
pendant un certain temps
croyez-le inverse de ce que vous tenez
le plus à coeur sans oublier
complètement votre point de départ
mettez vous dans les deux chaussures
pour revenir au cratère de soulèvement
et ma jolie petit puy de dôme j'ai écrit
finalement un article scientifique que
j'ai envoyée à bout le teint
volcanologique j'avais deux lecteurs qui
m'ont fait savoir qu'ils avaient
d'autres points de vue différents que le
mien mais dans l'introduction
j'avais mis cette histoire devant bourg
et là elle donc ils m'ont proposé qu'on
ait changé les chaussures et finalement
on a sorti quelque chose de le
convergence de tous nos points de vue
qui était beaucoup plus belles beaucoup
plus large que mon idée de départ
pour finir nous savons que les billets
sont très puissantes
même si on est conscient de leurs
actions on peut pas les empêcher
essayez vous même mettez vous dans les
chaussures d'un autre ou mieux porter
une chaussure et voyez où ça vous amène
merci